salut c'est monsieur greu raid hydrogène
one est ce que ça vous parle la société
great america qui fabrique des caméras
professionnelles qui peuvent filmer en
4k en 8k et surtout faire du format raw
pour la vidéo société red annoncé
qu'elle allait sortir un smartphone raid
hydrogène one qui pourrait bien
bousculer les codes
ce smartphone serait équipé d'un écran
holographique alors déjà on va regarder
ce qu'est un écran holographique on va
regarder qu'à ce que ce smartphone
pourra voir dans le bide et on va se
demander les écrans holographiques
seront utiles la prochaine révolution du
smartphone et on y va maintenant
[Musique]
qu'est ce qu'un écran holographique un
écran holographique par des d'avoir une
vision en trois dimensions mais sans
lunettes
alors comment ça marche un écran
holographique permet d'imiter la vision
stéréoscopique de nos yeux pour avoir
une vision en relief pour avoir une
vision en trois dimensions on a besoin
de deux yeux c'est ce qu'on appelle la
vision stéréoscopique
lorsque le cinéma avait cherché à
reproduire une image en trois dimensions
il va travailler avec une caméra avec
une double lentille séparer de 6,5 cm
exactement comme nos yeux 6,5 cm c'est
la distance qui sépare nos deux yeux
pour le cinéma les deux images sont
projetées directement son seul et même
écran ce qui fait que lorsque vous les
regarder sans lunettes vous avez une
image qui est franchement dégueulasse
[Musique]
du coup utilité bientôt trois dimensions
pour séparer la partie concernant l'oeil
gauche et la partie pour l'oeil droit et
après c'est notre cerveau qui fait le
reste nour constitue une image en trois
dimensions et c'est là vous profitez au
cinéma d'une image complètement détaché
dans le quatre smartphones c'est
fondamentalement différent vous avez pas
besoin de lunettes ça va pas travaillé
du tout de la même manière
donc on va regarder comment sont auto
smartphones et qu'est ce qu'il ya à
l'intérieur
côté spécifications techniques il a un
écran de 5,7 pouces avec une résolution
de 2560 parmi les quatre cent quarante
pixels et surtout les nouvelles
technologies pour l'écran sa technologie
phare view 4 vue fort vu comme vous
voulez en anglais dans ça plutôt fort
view qui lui permet de passer d'un écran
2 dimensions comme ce qu'on a sur nos
smartphones classique à un écran en
trois dimensions un écran holographique
une fois en trois dimensions vous allez
pouvoir visualiser les vidéos et les
photos en trois dimensions alors c'est
pas de la trois dimensions comme cinéma
qui la ressortir l'image avec un relief
mais plutôt de la trois dimensions un
petit peu comme sur une nintendo 3ds est
à dire ajouter de la profondeur de
vraiment espèce de profondeur de champ
lui dire ça comme ça c'est pas
exactement ça n'est vraiment que vous
ayez l'impression d'une immersion et
d'une réelle profondeur en images
alors vous me dire regarder de la 3d
d'accord mais d'un autre côté qu'est ce
qu'il ya en 3d aujourd'hui il n'y a pas
de vidéo qui sont disponibles en 3d avec
cette techno ya pas grand chose alors
non non c'est clair que non on n'en est
qu'au tout début
l'après clairement vous allez pouvoir
passer des appels d'un raid hydrogène
one à un autre c'est à dire avec deux
smartphones équipés de la même
technologie pour pouvoir effectivement
vous voir en trois dimensions avec cette
profondeur vous allez également pouvoir
filmer en trois dimensions vous allez
pouvoir faire des photos et les vidéos
en trois dimensions et vos smartphones
que vous allez pouvoir visionner
directement et uniquement dessus
d'ailleurs ça fait penser aux crs j'ai
vu une télé en trois dimensions sans
lunettes
la chose se rendra pas compte
directement l'image mais la télé quand
on regarde regarde les lunettes en 3d
sur les yeux l'image se détache vraiment
c'est très très étrange parce que on
regarde un écran et pourtant on a de la
3d dès qu'on bouge c'est hyper
particulier mais c'est vraiment un truc
de fou c'était probablement un système
qui était relativement différent là sur
ce smartphone vous avez deux caméras à
l'avant vous avez très probablement
aussi un capteur infrarouge qui
reconnaît en permanence la position de
votre visage et qui va adapter
l'affichage la 3d pour qu'elle soit la
même quel que soit votre position
c'est-à-dire que vous soyez face à votre
smartphone que vous bouger un petit peu
vous aurez toujours la même profondeur
et vous aurez pas un décalage là sur la
télé que j'ai vu au csa las vegas était
relativement différent mais c'est hyper
bluffant côté puissance on va voir un
snapdragon 835 peut-être 4 6 8 gigas de
ram pour l'instant aucune info
concernant le stockage mais on imagine
qu'il va falloir quand même beaucoup de
stockage si vous aller filmer en 8k ya
vous falloir des cartes mémoires énorme
et des cartes mémoires très rapide parce
que la lecture d'un fichier en full hd
en 4k et en 8k
c'est pas tout à fait la même chose on a
forcément une grosse batterie qui va
venir contrebalance un petit peu la
consommation de l'appareil d'une
batterie de 4500 millan paire eur et il
devrait tourner sous android nougat le
design est franchement particulier assez
loin de ce qu'on retrouve actuellement
un design assez industriel avec des
petits reliefs sur le côté à l'avant de
caméras on à peu près pas recevoir la
face avant sur une vidéo de marque elle
brandit son côté on a un bouton rec qui
montrait clairement que c'est un produit
qui est destiné à la vidéo de l'usb type
c'est un port jack des haut parleurs
stéréo situé en dessous de l'écran
pourra vraiment une autre façon
d'immersion on imagine la sensation
d'immersion est encore plus présente
encore plus puissante avec un casque
avec une répartition stéréo
ça devrait quelque chose de super
intéressant à voir également si on n'a
pas des micro stéréo située à l'avant de
l'appareil lorsque vous allez vous
parler directement sur un équivalent du
facetime pour vous puissiez vraiment
avoir une spatialisation du son
bon alors je vous arrête tout de suite
un se produit il est quand même
relativement cher vous avez deux
versions une version d'aluminium a
295 dollars et une version titanium à
1595 dollars il est bien précisé sur le
site de red que c'est harry sont hors
taxes hors frais de port et en frais de
manutention
c'est à dire que si vous rajoutez une
tvr sur le produit à 1995 $ ca fait 1100
16 euros + 20 % de tva ça vous le monte
à 1339 et là je ne compte pas ni la
manutention l'île ports et sur le
produit en titanium 2595 dollars on
passe un 1375 euros plus d'un
pourcentage à 1650 euros une fois de
plus centré nos intentions et sans frais
de port je sais pas si vous avez regardé
la vidéo de hummer si vous avez fait
attention mais on voit très clairement
qu à l'arrière et des petits connecteurs
qui vont servir à brancher des éléments
supplémentaires
un peu comme ceux pour trouver sur le
motorola moto cède comme ça l'appareil
qui est dédié vidéo on imagine vraiment
branché différents objectifs à l'arrière
par contre smartphones il y aura pas de
recharge à induction il sera pas
résistant à l'eau après est-ce que vous
en avez besoin
suis pas convaincu par la question qu'on
peut se poser c'est à qui est il destiné
parce que c'est quand même un produit
que très particulier vraiment orienté
vidéo vidéo plutôt pro un tarif qui est
quand même très élevé à qui est destiné
ce produit pour moi il est pas destiné
au grand public il est vraiment destiné
déjà aux amoureux de la vidéo n'est même
plus que ça il est destiné aux
professionnels à tous ceux qui utilisent
des caméras red c'est à dire qu'ils vont
pas vraiment l'utilité d'un matériel
comme celui là là vous voyez le tarif du
produit nu mais comme vous avez pu citer
pourra brancher des modules dessus ces
modules vont forcément coûter cher on
connaît privé l'objectif alors d'un
objectif spécialement conçu pour un
smartphone comme celui la duchère raid
ça va vous coûter une blinde et si vous
en voulez plusieurs ça va vous coûter de
bras d'autant plus qu'on imagine
vraiment que ce produit là vous allez
pouvoir utiliser comme un moniteur donc
lorsque vous avez votre caméra red vous
le prenez ça vous fait un petit moniteur
à distance donc il ya vraiment un sens à
usage professionnel en droit vous
permettra d'avoir une caméra
professionnelle en permanence dans votre
poche ou en tout cas très facile d'accès
dans votre sac
même ses smartphones n'est pas dédiée à
tout le monde l'écran lui pourrait
vraiment être intéressant pour tout le
monde
alors qu'en est il de cet écran ce qu'on
voit c'est que la technologie utilisée
au niveau cet écran pour l'instant n'est
pas déployé c'est vraiment tout premier
smartphone à l'avoir probablement ray
d'un brevet là dessus une innovation
technologique beaucoup n'imaginent pas
trouvé cet écran partout très rapidement
très clairement non mais par contre
c'est super intéressant parce que ce
qu'on voit c'est que c'est une vraie
technologie vraiment hyper intéressante
pour l'instant va pas les retrouver
partout donc pour moi on a vu qu'elle
existe et on a donc c'est intéressant
maintenant on va mettre dans un coin de
notre tête et on va oublier - vous
rouliez dépenser une petite fortune pour
accès ce produit qui était en pré
commande
il n'y a pas très longtemps sur le site
de red qui pour l'instant n'est plus
disponible
bon il devrait disponible rapidement sur
internet ou des trois pré commander
l'acheter à moins que vous ayez un
budget illimité pour la chaîne hbo
smartphones
je suis pas sûr qu'ils aient un réel
intérêt aujourd'hui parce que personne
en tout cas très peu de monde n'aura ce
smartphone donc vouloir profiter de
l'écran holographique tout seul vous
filmez et vont regarder films et vos
copains et lagreat sur votre écran et
c'est tout donc est-ce que les écrans
holographiques seront la prochaine
révolution niveau des smartphones
difficile à dire
en attendant on peut voir c'est vraiment
quelque chose de dix paires intéressant
et pan coup ça vraiment l'intérêt d'être
novateur alors sur ce smartphone ce
qu'on voit c'est qu'on a effectivement
la possibilité de pouvoir brancher des
petits malls derrière comme on a sur le
mode oz c'est bien c'est pas
révolutionnaire c'est bien ça peut
vraiment être intéressant pour apporter
différant objectif sur ce smartphone
dans le cadre d'un smartphone délit
vraiment à la vidéo et même pourquoi pas
à la photo mais l'idée de cet écran avec
une projection holographique sas a
vraiment un sens et ça pour le coup
c'est vraiment hyper intéressant pas
tout de suite comme je le disais on va
garder européenne note tête et on va
attendre voir si les différents
constructeurs se positionne là-dessus à
voir s'ils sont pas bloquées au niveau
des brevets à voir si réd fournit les
écrans voir un petit peu comment tout ça
peut être distribué voir si les
constructeurs s'y intéressent voir si
les développeurs s'y intéressent voir
s'il ya des applications qui peuvent
être proposées là dessus on peut
imaginer vraiment de profiter vraiment
d'une immersion on sait qu'au niveau des
smartphones il ya déjà le toucher haïti
qui est en train de se développer si
retoucher des écrans avec une espèce de
micro des formations pour avoir à
toucher différents en fonction de ce que
vous allez avoir comme l'utilisation de
smartphones à ce noir différentes
applications
ça peut déjà très intéressant mais
pourquoi pas en plus salées rajouter
là-dessus de la profondeur avec un écran
holographique
c'est vraiment une vision du futur du
smartphone que je trouve en tout cas
super intéressante
dites moi ce que vous en pensez en
commentaire est ce que vous pensez vous
ça pourrait vous intéresser alors pas
forcément sur ce produit parce qu'il va
quand même coûté très cher n'est pas
dédiée à tout le monde ça je voulais
déjà dit moi néanmoins si vous pourriez
vous laisser tenter
est ce que vous connaissez l'univers
raid est ce que vous êtes un amateur de
cinéma est-ce que vous avez déjà pu
tester ces caméras pourquoi pas si vite
vous marquez tout ça en commentaire et
est-ce qu'un smartphone comme celui là
pourrait vous intéresser
et qu'est ce que vous pensez de cet
écran holographique marquer ma tout ça
en commentaire comme d'habitude les
tables des cds jolie pousse à vous
abonner parce que vous allez voir on a
parlé toujours plus de tech tour plus de
smartphones de techno de plein de choses
innovantes
il ya plein de surprises qui arrive donc
restez connectés je vous embrasse et à
bientôt
tiens